the Ein Stelling effect the successful
deliberate approaches that we learned
during our development can become a
prison which stops us from being more
free flowing and at ease when we are
developed the tools that got you from
not to 50 are not the same ones that get
you from 50 to 90 but we found success
with this approach in the past so we
cling on to an overly rational
deliberate approach there was this time
I was in Boston and I was running on a
tread machine and I always do 10 km on
this tread machine when I do 10 km I get
this physiological signal that I'm tired
I landed in Boston I've got a talk later
that day the tread machine doesn't have
the kilometer dial on it so I can't see
how fast I'm running so I think okay
I'll do it the other way around I'll
wait for the signal in my body telling
me I'm tired and then I'll get off I run
and I run and I run and I run I'm like
I'm not getting tired I keep running
running run running I look up at the T
I'm going to have to get off at this
treadmill at some point I hit the button
21 km I was perplexed every time I run
10 km I feel knacked it was just a
limiting belief a wall I'd built and I
told myself that was my limit but they
are just figments of our imagination